des dépouilles de soldats russes sont
assez sur le sol par dizaines le début
d'un long travail d'identification pour
ses équipes médicales l'ukrainienne
les sacs mortuaires sont ensuite placés
dans ces wagons réfrigéré en attendant
d'être renvoyé en russie
certains des corps ont des signes
d'identification comme des tatouages ou
des crucifix on peut ainsi mieux les
identifier
certains ont des insignes militaires sur
la quarantaine de combattants russes
seules cinq ou six sont des papiers
d'identité sur
le décompte macabre se poursuit à mesure
que les militaires russes sont repoussés
de la région de ras kif une
contre-offensive ukrainienne qui semble
porter ses fruits dans cette vidéo des
soldats pose fièrement autour d'une
borne aux couleurs du drapeau ukrainien
et annoncent avoir repris le contrôle de
cette zone les forces de défense
territoriale ont atteint la frontière
avec la russie le pays occupant nous
sommes arrivés monsieur le président
nous y sommes
leur progression s'est faite village
après village ces dernières semaines
partout dans la région on peut voir les
pertes essuyées par les forces russes
leur véhicule militaire pulvérisé la
localité de ville kiffca 30 km de la
frontière russe porte encore les
stigmates de l'occupation les habitants
constatent l'ampleur des dégâts
c'est possible que les russes reviennent
je sens qu'ils peuvent revenir et ça
m'inquiète
un scénario peu probable pour l'heure
car les russes ont transféré leurs
troupes vers la région de lougansk dans
le donbass où elles concentrent
désormais leurs offensives